last week I asked you really close
what's wrong with me do I have to yell
all the time how did I forget about
Hawaii
I forgot Lawai my favorite show
YouTube's favorite show I forgot to fail
me now there's gonna be a bunch of
outdated means what the Frick top I
always go top and then past week but
it's been over a frickin week let's
freaking go gamers
why would someone named their little
girl Ilan s mhm
Ilan met a nine year old Henry that's
amazing how many times are we gonna post
days look how much taller I am the Joe
Joey Joey says he's 181 okay then how
tall am I then excuse me if Joe is 181
that means I'm 262 at least so I think
this proves lunch overall that I even
though I have giant shoes I'm still
extremely tall I am a giant the Swedish
giant they used to call me back in
school I never said this no
microtransactions no loot boxes and no
he won't be adding them a single-player
Star Wars story for those of you who are
ready to become a Jedi it was based in
several too simply I feel bad when you
watch the conference's of the people
that do actual the actual developers
who's worked on the game and they seem
so passionate and so involved that they
it is an actual good game and I think
for them to put all this effort to be
ruined by almost you could say politics
around microtransactions whether you
like them or hate them people obviously
like that that's why they buy them
it's a shame so I'm glad I'm glad that
finally there's none of it you know you
can argue either Felix camera Martius
camera there's amazing scientific
achievements of course it's gonna be
reduced to [ __ ] low tier PvP memes oh
look there's more on them
something made the frickin HD doubt
that's so mean this is hate speech of
any kind huh
pity pie at home PewDiePie in Japan
alright guys I'm trying to figure out
the camera alright I understand now what
I think the message has been going
getting through when you realize that
the picture of the black hole shows what
the black hole looked like 55 million
years ago is it 55 million light years
away without how that works
how does space and time works my cold is
really one of those concepts that
obviously this is not around black hole
but it's one of those concept that it
hasn't really been explored in in sci-fi
even though they are so crazy to think
about I think I read something from
Stephen Hawking what that was like if
you go near a black hole regret the
gravity is so strong that he will
stretch your whole body out like
spaghetti I want to become gravity
spaghetti sounds awesome
pity pie is a white male Hitler is also
white male coincidence I think not this
format has been with the comments have
been on every single one of my videos
Petey pine laughs he's making fun of
people with the pressure pity pine limbs
are you making fun of tying people felix
has parents are you making fun of
orphans how is it still going
no visible how badly do you want me I'm
shaking right now
how's it going bros my name is b-vector
a nine year old happiness noise that
original clip is when the dog sneezes
okay so so it kind of ruins the me for
me knowing the context the Egyptians
were truly more advanced than this you
know feast a stone brofist this is
actually you guys have figured out huh
this is a I'm actually made this 2,000
years ago is that what the Egyptians
leave so that now in present-day we can
have a stone fist 400 mil that would be
epic a bit of a hypocrite
against Peter Piper racist joke it's on
a show that uses racism and racism and
sexism as germs oh my god checkmate Wil
Wheaton blood I bet we written doesn't
have a G fuel sponsorship so joke's on
you will Whedon it's kind of sad how
things people turn out because I don't
think we'll Whedon is a bad person I
hear me out this is just purely
speculation and I have no idea if this
is true but I think a lot of people just
struggle with themselves and they kind
of project that onto other people
and they project people to be worse than
they are and kind of lift themselves up
I don't know where we I don't know
anything about him but I get that a
feeling from me I've watched some of his
shows he doesn't seem like a bad person
I think he's probably struggling with
some sort of mental illness and he's
just latching out onto the world and
this is making it even worse for himself
pure speculation I have no idea that's
true normal happy people don't act like
this that's my point
post my loan be quavo congratulations
5.5 million congratulations
5.6 million likes me absolutely did it
now if we can just hit 1 billion views
no problem no problem
easy peasy well billion that's easy when
you're literally the most powerful and
destructive entity in the known universe
but some weird ape make you into a meme
cries and gravity don't sympathize with
a black hole
don't make me from the bad for her black
hole subscribe to Peter 5 since 2011 has
never purchased any of it going to try
for Lawai again really hope pewds well i
really hope you like it
oh my god that is a lot of cubes goddamn
whoa okay okay okay that is very epic ha
ha I love it thank you that's awesome
that's really really good thank you guys
thank you tall man big boy flying a 35
banner for his 9th anniversary thank you
beauty pie that's kind of cool
kids kids dead coincidence I think not
yeah he's been leading a double life
that's crazy I didn't know that that's
really crazy
it's my dad again get famous people owes
me where you get 85 dead to tell it
embarrassing childhood stories about he
has none because I was the perfect child
in every single way possible so there is
nothing to film here Mulla makes a
template out of the freak man sort by
numerous don't up for me hard to swallow
pills
Peter pie will most likely turn into a
vlogging channel one Felix start a
family with Marzia they're gonna baby
doing something no never
no you guys always hold everything I say
against me there's one thing you need to
hold against me it's this alright
I prefer Ricardo I said the real Ricardo
perfection much it's hidden in the room
saw that I took her in a pottery Bowl
and just looked at me weird she doesn't
understand it was for an important mean
things recorded in low quality annual
meeting Bigfoot UFO black hole and
pewdiepie guys soon
soon you're gonna be so amazed by the
quality you're gonna see pores and
everything mean review your life you
lose 14 euros Friday
facade happy wheels goat simulator the
walking dead amnesia that was a weird
period where there was just no memes
like 2014 2015 or 2015-2016 I don't
remember
post uber simulator mean that gets 17.1
a thousand that photo doesn't get only
why me download to be simulated today
the most relevant game of all time I
gotta say though I got it save you the
developer timelines who made this game
the greatest game of all time they're so
nice and they're so sweet and they're so
excited that people are actually getting
more into the game again and it really
is a game that deserves attention I
think it is such a glowing game and I'm
so proud of it and team who made it so
if you wanna check it out if you haven't
already or maybe you want to check out
the new updates we have crania and all
that new stuff so check it out
definitely you might even do it watching
PewDiePie
in 2010 watching PewDiePie in 2011
watching 55 in 2012 watch a 3/5 2013
watch your feet 5 in 2014 watching free
to pie in 2015 watching ok we get it we
get it
ok I would put it this way watching
PewDiePie in 2010 nothing what a pity if
I in 2011 ok starting to get something
why do you feel fine 2012 that's when
you get this one and then these years
were just cringy and then we get back on
track here on 2015 16 15 15 14 you know
a lot of people ask how did he land a
girl like Marcia they don't know my true
strength how's it going bros my name is
Reverend Peter - the people don't
realize it was Joey who said that like
he's subbed it
I told him to say it and then I minded
it sounds like I mean but he did it so
convincingly I think people don't
realize my name is
Beauty pine beats a music company with
music YouTube who there do you think you
are
guess what guys big shocker it didn't
even take 24 hours and the goddamn video
got copies right Sony ATV publishing
it's not dr. Phil they ever said that
they enjoyed the video or something like
that it's so neat to be be publishing
why nunny not only the good manga anime
Netflix Adam chase god damn here's a
little pickle might be my closet I buy
all the Mart excluding but can you do
this merch sub speed fiber and a
probably my credit card and also waiting
for two goodies hope I pass the news
you went to pee in the middle of the
video but didn't wash for legal reasons
and a joke blue screen for Brad to
insert his own me there you go Brad go
crazy put your favorite meme in there
that's it for this week's you can
favorite show thank you guys for
watching
always a pleasure cannot believe I
forgot little why they sweet merch check
out super simulator check out don't need
to pulling everything every 10 seconds
absolutely brofist and 100 million baby
let's get to burst simulator it's now so
relevant that it's got a brand new mini
game cranium drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys
like